i wanted to get your take on something
that's obviously extremely
controversial and polarizing at the
moment because i've spoken with
people from both sides and i wanted to
kind of you know get your
understanding of uh what's going on
you know in israel and palestine because
you know i i've talked to
artists like belly and you know certain
people who are extremely passionate
you know on the palestinian side and
i've talked to some of my jewish friends
and
you know i always stay away from
subjects that i don't fully understand
um
and i i think i might have saw you weigh
in on what andrew yang said
maybe i'm wrong on that yeah so
um you know for people who don't know
you're jewish um what are your
i guess kind of what's your consensus or
your thoughts about
about everything that's going on man
so this is an incredibly
uh complicated subject and i'm not i'm
not saying that just like in a light
generic way um you know it's a subject
that sort of like
you know dominated the conversation in
my house my whole life
um you know and like i
i went to israel for the first time when
i was four years old right
israel's super important uh to my family
and to all jews um however
uh you know decency
and and and empathy and critical
thinking
can allow us to have a lot of love for a
place
and still be critical um i am not going
to oversimplify the entire thing because
the truth is
palestinians have been um marginalized
um they've been in many situations just
treated like garbage like just not
treated in
a humane way um and it's it's sickening
and upsetting
um and simultaneously
you know israel israel's existence is
important to the jewish people and
there's some people who don't agree with
that
inherently they do not believe israel
should should exist that that is a real
faction of people that exists
unfortunately hamas is in that category
right
right so you have these people who have
been
caught in a terrible position uh the
palestinian people
and we had opportunities at peace in the
past um
with robin and arafat which were
destroyed
and you know now you have
a really complex circumstance but the
bottom line is this
i hold the israeli government to a high
standard because that's
number one because of the the the money
the power the organization
the u.s backpacking and also because i'm
jewish and
and i believe in a jewish state so i
hold
in my sense my people right if you will
to a standard
i i'm not some person who believes you
just
wave the flag of your country blindly or
whoever
willy-nilly like it's i know this sounds
silly and crude
but i always go back to sports and i
know you're a sports fan so
i love the washington football team so
much
i hate the owner i publicly tell
everyone i hate the owner
i want him to sell the team i don't want
it to have anything to do with the team
i first suggested and and demanded the
name be changed like
13 years ago or something on camera that
was the first time publicly
right i still love the team i still
rooted for the team
while literally not wanting them to even
have their name
sort of look at the way we we deal with
our countries of origin the same way
just because you love israel and see its
existence as important
does not mean you have to believe in
everything
they do and and also
just because you're a palestinian does
not mean
that you do or should ride with hamas
right so it's an it's a it's a really
bad situation
i think that netanyahu has been
generally terrible
and i've some of my jewish friends have
compared him
to like if trump won over there like
he's extremely right-wing
extremely he's only got right wing over
the years right because it
became a winning thing because we're
seeing this whole like
real real white nationalism all across
the world
and he he's written with going further
right as the years have gone on
so you know
how could if i if i felt the way i felt
about trump which was that he was
an absolute nightmare in the worst and
guess what you can still love america by
the way and still feel that way
yes exactly right and now i understand
it's complicated for jews though right
because when we start hearing
israel get criticized the history of the
jewish people isn't the same history
as a court of america a hundred percent
yeah
america's like the white people of
countries right
it's gonna be all right yeah i think
that the the thing that's that's that's
hard is like
obviously i what i've noticed is anyone
who has spoke out against
the actions of the israeli government it
seems as if they get
labeled right away as being an
anti-semitic person
well the thing is you have to look at
each individual's person
separately that's fair but i mean i've
seen i've seen like i think dua lipa
they're trying to call her
you know people have just made
statements that saying you know
essentially hey what's going on is wrong
it seems like there's there's like a
narrative that goes right away
on twitter or you know that these people
are quote unquote anti-semitic and i
think that everyone can be
you know critical of you know like you
said
you could be critical of a country or
government's actions and still
be with the jewish people you know what
i mean and you know